this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode Jonathan is taking a look
at the World War One era Weaponry of
izonzo Villar peroza as its nearly
universally named that's beautifully
modeled as this is I did immediately
spot something which is that again you
can't just rip out magazines if you can
you've failed as a magazine designer or
as a gun designer if there are any other
games guns and mechanics that you guys
want to see Jonathan break down let us
know in the comment section below and if
you'd like to help out the Royal
armories Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to Jonathan
[Music]
the stair m1912 or Han distinctive for
well the clip loading guide on the top
uh the big blocky rear sight and that
sort of barrel key disassembly system at
the front is reminiscent of sort of old
sporting muzzle loaders and things it
looks like everything is pretty much
as it ought to be
there are a few variations in these over
the years and the markings do vary the
big thing about the the stair Hunt is no
detachable magazine this is a sort of
last gasp
of the load it from the top broom handle
Mauser style hence it will always lock
open you can load it the way that we saw
initially if you attempt to insert a
single round as we saw there whether the
around is dropped in loose and then
pressure is applied with the thumb if
you do that you'll end up with stay a
thumb
unless you first put on that latch that
will manually hold the slide to the rear
you can then
push rounds in one at a time because the
only sort of feed lip that's stopping
that's that's holding them in after you
let go is essentially it was connected
to this release latch so you can load it
singly by far the most efficient way to
load it is the second method with well
strip off a full clip either way you
would then press down on press down on
the slide release and the weapon is then
chambered you can then put it on safe
and carry it around to do that you
actually have to pull back on the hammer
and push up so there may be a couple of
details of the sort of Manual of arms
that are not modeled in the game or just
not seen because it's not necessary I
don't think we're using the safeties so
it's not really a problem but I mean
that is a problem but it's not a problem
in the game
foreign
what we seem to have here is a weapon
for firing fence posts I know nothing of
this system I must admit I'm guessing
it's a an improvised or semi-improvised
trench mortar it's spigot mortar in in
technical terms that much I can tell
we've got a wing nut for adjusting
elevation and some sort of pipe bomb
type munition with fairly hilarious not
hilarious if you're having to fight in
the first world war but nonetheless fuse
hanging down at the rear which we are
lighting with a sort of with a cigarette
lighter I think all I'm sure faithful to
the original if not something that we we
have here the one one thing I possibly
can criticize is that bit of fuse
because it doesn't seem to burn down I
could be missing something here I don't
know the system but just touching a
flame to the end of that bit of string
wouldn't seem to be sufficient to ignite
it if it's fused it ought to burn down
before firing if it's actually a lanyard
that you're supposed to pull well then
you shouldn't be setting light to it so
I'm sure I'm missing something there
stay long
right next up the Madsen this is a
hugely important gun historically used
by dozens of Nations now I'm I am not
very familiar with this particular
theater and period of History the
Madison absolutely fits chronologically
technologically tactically not sure that
we have hard evidence of either side
using it or at least I haven't seen it
just in cursory online research I'd be
very surprised if there isn't some
evidence for the austro-hungarian Empire
using it and hence why it's been
included in this game I'm just saying I
can't really confirm or deny the extent
to which either side used it the thing
that jumps out to me is the ripping the
magazine out without operating the
magazine catch I haven't got one to hand
but I don't think that would work it has
a Bren style magazine catch and what
what may have thrown them off here is
that skilled users will use the heel of
the hand to activate the magazine as
they come in and rock the magazine out
everything else looks good rectifier
sounds right you've got the crank style
cocking handle and being able to run
around with it like you know as a sort
of assault machine gun as it were yeah
it's light enough and handled on a
handle the ball no that you can do that
okay really interesting machine gun the
Ravalli model 1914 often called the
theater Valley because the Fiat company
famous Fiat company made them I have
just grabbed the aircraft gun version so
the back half is is as you see in the
ground gun because it's the same gun so
we've got the receiver extension out the
back
which is essentially empty space and is
really just to give you enough clearance
for this wacky
horned Bolt to come out to the rear so
the other weird thing about this gun is
this crazy feed block cage whatever you
call it it's essentially a row of sort
of pistol magazines with their
independent Springs and followers and
we've got some inert rounds on this
block to show you roughly how it works
so it comes in from the left side just
as you see in the game and that's what
it looks like so you'd have a carrying
kit with several of these in and they're
firing in sequence and then the gun that
advances it to the next spot and then
the next string so it's like semi-full
automatic in in a way now something I
noticed in the game I'm not super
familiar with these so I could be
missing something but I have not found a
bolt hold open on this pulling the bolt
all the way to the rear and it's staying
there for loading I haven't seen that I
have not looked at the rate of fire on
the on the ravelli I must admit this
seems maybe a bit high and it almost
seems like the bolt is out running the
feed device if that makes sense so when
a short burst is fired the bolt comes
back twice two cases come out the block
doesn't move but then firing continuous
strings the bolt doesn't seem to be
reciprocating enough times to have fired
a complete row of cartridges that maybe
it's me but maybe that maybe that it's
not quite synced up as it thought to be
quite a quirky gun and it's nice to see
it in a game for what has to be the
first time
[Music]
the stair m95 infantry rifle I am
looking here at a sort of overhead pass
on this beautifully modeled virtual m95
very impressed with it ours is actually
in better condition than the one in the
game I'm not gonna say that's a
criticism at all because it's amazing
how quickly infantry weapons can can
look old depending it's more about the
the service they've seen where they've
seen it in what sort of usage and it's
incredible how they can quickly look
like military surplus in actual use but
it really does look good
foreign
as well I like the slight fisheye effect
of the Optics I wonder if that's
strictly accurate all of all of the late
19th century Optics I've looked through
have been pretty pretty optically
correct maybe the scope that they used
for reference had that of that effect
maybe they all do in this case I don't
know but typically by the late 19th
century you know the Victoria's new
Optics they could grind flat Optics just
as well just with more time and cost
pretty much as we do today so don't know
if that Distortion is actually Fair as
it were I did notice that the player is
finger and thumbing the bolt which is
easily doable when the cocking piece is
back when they're gonna cough it's a
little awkward to do in the way depicted
they're not impossible by any means when
you've got the spring pressure to
overcome I would expect more of a grip
like this so using the meat of the hand
finger and thumb but that support of the
hand and much easier and more repeatable
especially when you've got cartridges in
in the weapon that are going to induce
extra friction extra drag the most
important thing for me if I was advising
on something like this is find some
manuals and try to try to replicate that
because even if people deviated in
actual combat at least you've got a
frame of reference and and you can say
to anyone that criticizes is where we
got the sauce
all right
we've got a revolver here sidearm but
it's looking good to me I do have a
number of these in the collection the
rust and Gasser so another very end of
the 19th century design not too unusual
but it's it has that slightly cludgy
clunky late 19th century revolver design
where we haven't quite settled on the
most efficient way to do a double action
revolver speaking of double action it's
a bit jaunty in its firing animation I
think they're trying to get across the
physical difficulty of pulling through
on what is actually quite strong double
action trigger pull on these and hence
that we're almost snatching the shots so
it's just just something I noticed it
definitely is an issue you cannot keep
the sights bang on target when you're
yanking through on a double action
trigger pull looking at the the close
detail of this those cartridges they
have very dark primers I guess that's
modeled off a real one that's maybe aged
or something or perhaps there was a lot
on the primer on these I don't know good
reload though we've got a the ejector
rod on the side being used to to knock
out around and then replacing it with a
live rotate the cylinder rinse and
repeat until you've replaced all of your
fired cartridges
[Music]
right first reaction wow that's that's
really detailed so it's a we've got a
Beretta 1915 self-loading pistol that's
in as it says on the slide nine
millimeter and it is yes 9M not nine
nine mm on this pistol so I have one
here now this is a this is our nicest
example but it does have it has been I
think refinished in service because the
text is actually a bit blurry so if you
can't see that on camera it does in fact
say exactly what this says on the side
my one nitpick is and my first
impression was that looks a bit Resident
Evil
it looks like the the text on a Resident
Evil gun and that's because the font
isn't right so the font is a font with
serifs or Hooks and bumps on the on the
corners of the letters uh whereas it's
just block capitals on the on the real
gun the actual text the way it's
presented is great and it shows a level
of attention of D to detail the problem
is the more details you get the more
little branching tiny details micro
details you can fall into the Trap up so
that's that's why I'm harping on about
that
okay
um handling wise good we've got
one-handed operation typically at this
time pistol Shooters would adopt a bent
elbow bent wrist grip a little bit of a
raised eyebrow on the overhand slide
operation that's a very recent
development then again I don't know
first world war Italian training
pamphlets maybe they did but I'd be very
surprised the the sort of received
wisdom on cocking a self-loading pistol
with a slide by this time was turn it to
one side grasp the serrations pull to
the rear and release I'd be pretty
surprised if anyone's Magpul power
stroking their Beretta 1915 but of
course people are free to deviate from
training
that's excellent we have a hold open
system on this as we're used to on
self-loading pistols holes open on the
empty magazine you know you're empty
great so that's where we're used to that
The Quirk with this with the Beretta or
this Beretta is as depicted so when you
pull out the magazine it's the magazine
that's holding open or magazine follower
that's holding open the slide there's
the the followers not operating a hold
open device the follower is the hold
open device meaning a lot of effort
required to pull out that magazine and
when you do the slide goes forward which
means all this is is an empty weapon
indicator it's not a convenience for
reloading because you insert your Fresh
Magazine you're gonna have to
fully operate the slide again so they've
got it absolutely right
[Music]
all right now this is a bit of vintage
kit by even 19 not first of all war
standards this example from our
collection is basically identical to the
one in front of me it has a bit of extra
history to it and so this is the vitally
Vitali so this is prior generation
Italian service rifle I assume it's it
was used by Reserve troops in the first
world well it was used by reserves used
in the first World War I assume they're
meant to be present in the game hence
the presence of this vintage rifle a
really nicely modeled gun again and here
any wear and tear is absolutely expected
because these things have been knocking
around for decades by this point so it
would look a bit antique you can see the
very interesting clip system there we
have got one I don't have handy
unfortunately cardboard and steel with a
toggle on the top for pulling out the
cartridge because it's not a man look at
Style on block clip that stays in the
gun it is a stripper clip but it's this
slightly wacky way of doing it like
shove it in pull it out the rounds are
pretty huge this is a as befits a rifle
of this era it's on the 10 11 millimeter
order 10.4 millimeter caliber to be
precise so it's a big old heavy slow
Bullet by first world war standards
so we have a bayonetting we have
veterally bayonets they're big brutal
sword I mean Bandits are brutal but a
little bit indistinct there it's kind of
thrust in the direction of the enemy
enemy falls down there's a bit of red
that's not really a criticism every game
does bayonetting like that you don't
really get that visceral sense that you
are stabbing somebody with a knife on a
stick obviously the more the more
realistic you make that the more
disgusted people might be by it I don't
know I don't know if it's a technical
limitation or a sort of ethical one or a
bit of both but no no game really does
bayonetting very accurately maybe we
don't want them to
[Music]
foreign
universally named that's beautifully
modeled as this is I did immediately
spot something I'm sorry to say which is
that again you can't just rip out
magazines if you can you've failed as a
magazine designer or as a gun designer
and the villoparosa has these slightly
dodgy looking magazine catches at the
front you you could effectively rip them
out but you'd have to use your little
finger to actuate the magazine release
as you then ripped them out and you do
have to angle the mag quite far back
before it will clear the log so you have
to come out at sort of this angle so
pulling them straight out of the top of
the gun as as we seem to see here not so
much but the actual modeling of the gun
is really good all the components and
everything look to be that to be done
correctly when off the bipod and this
does make some sense only the right hand
Trigger is being
pressed holding it like a sort of
submachine gun if you're if you're
having to hold it like this you can't
easily fire both what you could of
course do is fly one
reach over high too rather than just
reloading the right hand side but hey
using the gun in a way it's not supposed
to be used you would make up whatever
system of operation you deem appropriate
[Applause]
I think there is a an unintended
consequence slight [ __ ] up with the way
this is set up in the game to fire only
one side when you're carrying it
handheld and that is when you do a
Reload you've still got your unspent
magazine on the left hand side on the
real gun when you [ __ ] it only one
cocking handle moves they are literally
independent guns they're not connected
in the game when you [ __ ] it it [ __ ]
both which would mean ejecting a live
round every time you reload your right
hand side of the gun and that isn't
modeled and wouldn't be correct
[Music]
right first impressions on this the m91
Carcano Cavalry carbine this looks great
we've got some really nicely done wood
on here and it almost looks like it
isn't just a texture the edges look
genuinely kind of I guess friable would
be the word where they've been abraded
over time we've got the notching out of
the handguard on top which is to
accommodate the flip forward battle site
or rather the the adjustable side flips
forward revealing the battle site
underneath and what's really impressed
me here are the fingerprints those are I
think are probably meant to be oily
fingerprints they do look like someone's
left a thin coat of oil on their weapon
as they probably should and then they've
grasped it with a thumb and it's left to
print it adds a level of sort of detail
that I hadn't even considered the idea
of putting fingerprints on on guns
foreign
sites here now bearing in mind this is a
slightly out of period scale replica of
the royal thing but correctly modeled we
can see our rear sight there and it's
correctly modeled with no doubt a
separately modeled folding adjustable
aperture now from what I've read of the
how the sights work with Italian rifles
you're actually supposed to use them
more like Buckhorn sites on something
like a Winchester in other words you
would put the tip of the front sight in
the bottom of the V for a given range
which gives you a different sight
picture than what we see here because
what the guys have done here is what
you'd expect 99 Firearms do and that's
to put the front sight level with the
rear sight that's in all the
Marksmanship lessons that have ever been
taught in history probably but in this
case is probably slightly wrong
foreign
system is shown is correct I don't know
if this is modeled but there is a way to
eject
the clip so we have here a full length
m91 Carcano this one's beautifully
sectioned so we can see how it works so
it works essentially like a like a
Garand insert your your clip against
spring tension until that latch can
click into place that's then in place
ready for the bolt head to pick up the
first round so I don't know if it's
modeled in the game this was a bug bear
of M1 Garand representation in games was
that you had to fire up all your shots
before you could reload the thing it's
not in the game yet I suspect they will
add it but it is possible on the Carcano
just like there's a Clipper jacked on
the Garand and you can even pop it part
way out and top it off in this case it's
that latch push forward on that I'm just
going to help it because it's a section
one but push forward on that latch and
then that sprung lifter will with some
Force eject your partial clip so if
you're trying to just take it out
partially empty you would need to grab
hold of it so it's a bit of a
three-handed job but it is possible to
reload partial clip to top off the rifle
so we've got an m91 rifle set up for
rifle grenade shooting and nicely we've
got our grenade propelling cartridge
being inserted straight into the chamber
so not using the clip which I assume is
how it's done for real and the way it
launches off the end looks looks pretty
good to me there's maybe not enough
recoil modeled because launching a
couple of pounds of iron and explosive
off the end of your gun really takes a
toll on the gun and on you and typically
rifle grenades were not fired from the
shoulder maybe these were but it would
be not fun typically they were fired
with the butt in the ground I'll have to
go in and look into that a bit more but
looking good
right so something new and well not
entirely new I suppose we've had
artillery represented in in games and in
First World War Games before but uh we I
think we're getting a lot more detail
and a lot more realism in the way that
this is shown to operate we can actually
see what's happening with the breach the
recoil the actual Gun Barrel is
recoiling in the carriage although this
is only it's only a 7.5 centimeter
Mountain guns a relatively small
artillery piece I'd still expect to see
it rocking back on the wheel slightly
like even if even if this has a super
efficient recoil system for its for its
caliber and a locking system for the
wheels and the trail is properly dug in
and everything I am not an artillery
specialist by the way despite my job
title I'm responsible for artillery at
Royal Ras but
I would expect it to at least move
slightly on those Wheels but other than
that it looks great the only thing we're
missing here is a sighting system so
we've got our reticle with that's got
our sort of modern grenade launcher
range stadia on it obviously you don't
see that in front of your eyes in real
life you'd need some sort of sighting
system and what we're really missing
here is the sense of a crew in reality
it's a team of several guys all who all
know their jobs incredibly well and work
as a synchronized team to to lay lay the
gun operate the gun reset the gun and so
many tasks involved in crewing a you
know a separate job in every Armed Force
for a reason
foreign
thanks for watching that was a bit of a
a marathon through the very splendidly
done guns of isonzo please do if you can
come and visit us at one of the three UK
sites of the royal armories if you can't
you can go and check out our YouTube
channel and our various social media
outlets and of course continue to watch
this series which will be back next week
[Music]
foreign